[Music]
hello and welcome to episode
100 of hang on
you gave up the right to do this you
don't get to do this anymore that's fair
you might be the podfather but you left
you left the house
you don't you don't you don't you know
you don't belong here anymore you're
just a guest this time mate
hello and welcome to gamespot after dark
i'm your host hussein yes it's me like a
father that left 10 years ago to pick up
some smokes
but then suddenly linda his kids are
talented and rich i'm back
is back is lucy james
i don't know how to introduce myself
after that
hi jean-luc hello
michael hyam hi i've been here and
the podfather himself returning once
again
is jake decker so xbox unlocked or
they got phil spencer for their 500th
episode and you guys got me for your
100.
you guys got ripped off this is this is
this is what we wanted like phil spencer
emailed me and said hey i heard you've
got your 100
100th episode do you want me on i said
no we've locked in jake decker and he
was like fair enough
he was like who yeah
i was like getting on game pass um as
mentioned there
yes this is uh this is a double
celebration
yeah this is the 100th episode of
gamespot after dark
a podcast that was created and pioneered
by jake
but it's also the 1 000th
video for one lucy james
1 000 videos the only reason we're doing
this on video
hey man can we do that video just now
all the comments is gonna be like
where's the rest of the video art we
needed it was 101 was one or two
99. this is it's just this one it's
literally when you like get your mates
to come online to grind a game just
because you need that trophy
this is the this is the podcast
equivalent of it i appreciate you all
uh we are we are doing a double
celebration what does that mean
it just means that we we we do a normal
podcast but with our friends
so great good times uh we don't need to
do
the uh the segment what was it what's
the segment called again
what's his name
i i don't care about chris anymore he
doesn't listen to his podcast chris
doesn't listen he stops he doesn't have
episode four yeah exactly he's gone do
listen
please let us know yeah i've tried that
i tried
if you don't if you don't if you don't
let us know somehow that you're
listening we're renaming the segment to
someone else
i think like we changed from california
segment
yeah we'll change it to the jake decker
from california segment
anyways what we've been playing i'm
gonna select
lucy to go first oh hello what you've
been playing what you've been doing what
you've been experiencing other than e3
not a lot uh no i'm kidding so i did uh
finished mass effect 3 finished mastery
trilogy had a lovely time
did a small cry but uh the thing i would
like to discuss
is that i saw fast nine yesterday
in 4dx because one of my friends
here in the uk uh literally refuses to
go see a movie unless it's 1040x
we went to see a quiet place too in 4dx
it gets surprisingly loud i don't know
it was good i had a nice time
but i will say i saw terminator 2 in 4dx
and
honestly like maybe top 10 moments of my
life i almost cried it was incredible
fast 9 in 4dx was very very good
that movie is so stupid
i had a really fun time there are bits
where
like obviously they ruined the whole han
stuff coming back like in a trailer
already but even the way they reveal him
in the film like me and my friend neil
just going like
yes um there are
just some absolutely outrageous stunts
like
rocket car going into space the whole
thing
there are just some real clangers of
lines but clang is to the point where
it's like oh that's a fast and furious
line so i still love it
um charlize theron for some reason is
wearing leather pants the whole time and
has a really terrible haircut that i
just couldn't get over
it's like those movies shouldn't work
and yet they do and i have really i had
a really fun time with
it and i i just was buzzing at the end
of it
but also i had i had loads of tension in
my back and
there's a scene like any car chase where
like bullets are flying the chair just
like pummels you so i was like oh this
is like being one of those
chairs you get at the airport it's
lovely
jake you've also seen it right what did
you think of it i did see it and the
only thing
i will ever remember from that movie is
the very strange star wars conversation
that happens like
that was
why is this in the movie it felt like an
intern wrote it and they were like well
he liked star wars or no it felt like
george lucas wrote that to be honest and
let's just keep it in is to pay homage
to him or something but it is so out of
place it's so strange
characters just start comparing
themselves to star wars characters but
it's almost as if it's like
lazy writing so they don't have to think
about their own
characters or archetypes or whatever
it's like let's just reference star wars
characters
yeah and then if it's so weird it sticks
out
so much i don't know how it didn't get
cut i i think
they were like oh let's try a little uh
uh god what's it called when
people don't i forget what it's called
but when people just say things that
come to their mind
improv that's the word yeah it felt like
it felt like an improv scene that
they're just like oh let's just leave it
in here
it's like oh that's pretty good it was
like i'm like luke skywalker and then
she's like no you're like yoda i'm like
yeah i'm like yoda
and then she said something like yeah
yoda dies like what
yes okay yo has a hand up his ass
controlling him because he's a pokemon
oh exactly
i felt like otto up until that point
the like this random bad guy
he hasn't really heard anything else and
that's his key scene
talking to charlize theron about star
wars yeah it's so weird it was it was an
enjoyable movie but i know that
in a year from now i'll forget all of it
except that scene
yeah it could be like setting the
foundation from when when they
inevitably transform it into a sci-fi
movie in space they went to school they
went to space they went to space no i
wasn't like when they fully get in thai
fighters and
yeah exactly that's the direction
they're going you said you send ted and
roman up to space dog yo
next thing is [ __ ] rocket cars with
lasers on them shits
i mean also they they do a really weird
thing where roman starts discussing
like he has this weird existential
crisis about how come they never die
oh yeah no it's it's really cute
it's really cute but it's also just like
him kind of thinking out loud hey do we
have plot armor
threat it's funny though and then half
the characters in that movie do have
plot armor
yeah they do no one no one dies i i
haven't seen this but i think
like the response to it that i've seen
is kind of like
much less into use than the expectation
and the
joy for going into it it feels like
people have
very much come out of it and they're
like in that phase where they're like
i have to act like i really enjoyed this
because i was so hyped going in
uh and like i'm i'm i'm i fear for the
future of that franchise now i feel like
you two left
i don't know there's not only two left
there's no way there's only two left
not in hell
the fast awakens and uh yeah the last
furious i don't know the furious
unleashed
yeah there is a mid-credit scene
and it did get me very hyped for what is
next
so yeah i'm gonna try and watch it soon
but yeah i
i i'm gonna go out there and say this
i'm probably gonna get [ __ ]
for it but i feel like we're at the
start of the decline of this series now
like this is pretty good
yeah i mean like they solid solid i mean
like solid run for the last few the
first few were
shot let's be honest but um wow come on
they became
yeah i mean like you like for the
culture you like your retro yeah for the
culture for the street culture but like
most people like those movies
retroactively
because of what the franchise the
context they put in because the new ones
but watch there when they're on it's
like i feel like we reached the peak
with uh was it a seven or eight so which
one's
well seven is the one where they take
the deal with people and an eight is
where it like
really hit i think the poor walker one
wiz was
where i like there's a plot twist and
eight that really just
got and i think it's because i watched
them all within like two weeks
yeah and i was like very very invested
seven was where everyone went oh this
franchise actually means something to
me and then eight is where people went
oh this is some
wild [ __ ] going on i'm into this and now
i feel like
it's it's the downward spiral is gonna
happen
yeah also hearing hearing how much
influence um
vin diesel has like do you hear about
that weird thing that like he and the
rock
had to trade like the same number of
blows and stuff but knowing
just how integral he is to the franchise
and i assume he has so much control
behind the scenes this is such a dumb
movie
but vin diesel is not good enough to
carry it
like can i say that with love because i
think dom torreira is an amazing
character
but there are some bits in this where he
has to show like different
like ranges of emotion and all i just
noticed him doing this at the very
beginning and then i couldn't stop
seeing it
but the only way he can show like
anguish is to purse his lips ever so
slightly
it's the same expression for everything
and like yeah he uses it so much like
this movie also there's like a flashback
scene
and i couldn't figure out who that was
meant to be
it's like a foot and a half taller than
vin diesel
my favorite thing about uh about that
whole kind of like uh inter
or dynamic between them is like because
the rock and
vin diesel like notoriously fell out and
they did not like each other
for a long time and then vin diesel
commented commented on it recently and
it was
he said that he was like behaving quite
like aggressively and demanding a lot of
the rock because he only wants
like he wants his movies to have the
best performances and
he pushes all his actors and everyone
just tweeted with like
vin diesel is pushing v actors for like
good performances
my man's own performances are like
trashed here
i was surprised they didn't name dom's
brother sub
wow oh my god wow that was not
like that's all i got i'm out that's it
that's it that would be uh in line no no
one would
mind that i think that would be
absolutely fine but yeah i'm gonna go
watch it this weekend
um we'll see how it goes hopefully this
weekend i'll see how i feel
uh jean-luc what you've been up to uh
i've been
poking around with a bunch of different
random things but uh
i recently hopped into uh halo the
master chief collection because they
just put out their
season seven elite uh which is
basically they've just been like doing a
thing for i don't know how long their
seasons last but like they
put on new seasons where they've been
fixing the games adding new content and
then
specifically they're adding like uh
stuff from
halo online which was that free-to-play
russian game i think oh yeah um
it's really weird so they're
[Music]
i'm of two minds of it because like
they're adding all of this like
extra armor that you can like put into
like halo 3 or halo 4 and they're adding
like
new maps from those and like it all
feels it doesn't feel cohesive
necessarily you know it like it kind of
straight from the original vision of the
the master chief collection where you're
like oh this is like preserving these
games and they're like
what if we put in this like random map
made by these like uh this other studio
into halo 3 and you play and you're like
yeah this is a map i guess i don't know
it's
okay like um like the new map they added
is like
it's a halo 3 map but all of the art
assets look like they're from halo 4.
it's like really weird
it doesn't mesh at all um
it's a strange experience um i don't
think you can filter the maps out that
i'm aware of i didn't see anything but
you can at least filter the armor out so
you can go to the settings and
if you want to like say i don't want to
see any of like the new armor
both on myself and other players you can
actually just go turn that off in the
menu which is kind of nice
it just like defaults everyone to like
the standard
spartan armor the standard elite armor
um
so that's cool uh but mostly i'm just
like it was just kind of fun to like hop
back into halo i was feeling that itch
after um
uh halo infinite and i was like yeah i
wanna play some halo
matchmaking is still like pretty good at
this point like there i had no issues
with it uh plenty of people are playing
it
they recently added um like a server
browser uh
it's in beta so it only works for reach
but like you can now just like
pull up like old school like
counter-strike style like here's a list
of like all these different servers with
like
you know uh like snipes only xxx no
noobs
uh 14 out of you know 16 players 200
ping and you're like all right let's go
i'm i'm gonna hop in uh so like it's
wild to see that in like a halo game
um on like our console because you're
like oh okay but like
it's cool that they're adding that [ __ ]
in there um and then
and then the other thing uh that's like
worth talking about with this update is
they actually went back and they
fixed um halo one um i don't know if you
guys are like aware of this but like
the uh halo one not the anniversary
version the original like og xbox
graphics um
are actually not correct um like if you
were to compare them to the original
xbox they they have like all these like
kind of broken
uh stuff where like certain lighting
things don't work or like the textures
on on like
stuff is wrong um and that is apparently
an issue that has gone all the way back
to like the og
um gearbox like pc release from like
2003
because that's the version they used to
port um halo 2 the master chief
collection
and so it's had all these issues for
years and like the fans have been asking
them like hey you're going to fix it
you're going to fix this because it's
like
it doesn't look as good as the original
xbox version um
and they finally have actually started
to like address all that stuff it's
it's really cool there's a really great
digital foundry video you can go check
out where they kind of like
detail all those changes um it's mostly
just like
i don't know it's like i have to commend
uh 343 for like
actually going out of their way to fix
that like that doesn't really happen
that often especially for
a game like what like it came out like
2014 that's like seven years ago
that the mass chief collection came out
yeah it's just i'm like continually
uh amazed that they're like still
updating that game i mean i know it's
like microsoft so they have like
all this money and they can throw it
because it's halo but like i
there was a period where i was like yep
this thing is dead and they're never
gonna
they're never gonna fix it so the fact
that they did i think is like it's
pretty cool
nice i actually played some halo master
chief collection on my
uh on my phone because i tried out yeah
xcloud for the first time oh yeah
because i think
i think they just added it to apple
products because before very very
recently
in browsers yeah i was just in the
living room like i set up my
phone i guess set it on the table i was
just playing some master chief
collection it worked surprisingly well
i don't know if i'd play multiplayer but
i was playing halo one
campaign and it was it was great like
connected my controller in two seconds
definitely give it a shot like you
probably won't play a lot with it but
it's just
it's kind of mind-blowing i really want
to do that because
um i really wanted to get backbone
and i didn't but now the x-cloud is on
ios properly i'm like
oh i could spat one's amazing
yeah but like i'm one of those people
who
i love sitting at a couch and playing a
game but there's nothing quite like
sunday morning cup of coffee in bed with
the game
but like yeah so i have a i have like a
small tablet i'm going to try
nice uh michael what you been up to
uh i play the neo the world ends with
you demo
and it was pretty much it's pretty much
the same as uh the preview that i
preview build i played uh a month or so
back so
i've and i talked about my experience
but now everyone else can experience it
because that demo
is out there and uh it's still pretty
cool uh i don't know how
like i'm i'm super into the combat
system and how they've uh
reworked it so that you don't have to
like obviously you can't rely on touch
controls because it's a
is also going to be on pc and uh ps4
and it's it plays like a plays like a
pretty standard action rpg but like the
pin system if you all play
uh twi before the pin system where you
can have all these different attacks and
stuff do we
oh my god grow up um but yeah it's uh
it's pretty fun i don't know how
how much how long that's gonna like if
if
that combat system is gonna wear off at
all at a certain point
i know you do get more party members you
do there's like over
like i think like 300 different pins
that you can mess around with so
there's a lot of variation i just don't
know how necessary it's going to be
because the fights so far have been
really fun but i don't see i like i had
like a certain setup and i was like okay
i'm good with this setup i don't
necessarily need
uh to mess with other ones but of course
that's just the demo which is like the
first three hours of the game
yeah but yeah that one that one's coming
out later this month
ah and squarenix i'm looking at you
to come through with them codes bro
yeah i wanna i wanna uh i'm very
interested i'm a lot more interested in
this game after like after playing the
preview i was like oh cool they're
making another
world ends with you then i played them
like oh [ __ ] this game is pretty dope
and it's i said this before when i talk
about the first time but now that we're
here
it has has that ad that young that
youthful attitude that's kind of cheesy
kind of corny but
i'm just like you know what i'm kind of
into it it makes me feel young again
um and uh yeah y'all should y'all should
peep that uh demos on ps4 and switch
uh i was playing on switch and it works
pretty well uh i've been yeah and i've
been using my switch quite a bit
because i also played monster 100
stories 2 which is also a demo
uh with progress that carries over that
is out sooner
actually i think that's not on the 9th
yeah um
it was one of the games at like we we've
seen monster hunter
stories too before e3 but it was
one of the games that stood out to me at
e3 i mean there wasn't
much to be honest uh um
especially during the capcom uh thing so
when capcom showed off
uh like showed a new trailer for monster
horror stories too and then was on
treehouse for
switch i was like oh snap this is this
might be up my alley i played
played the demo but i don't know if it's
for me man that the comment system is
like a rock paper scissors thing and you
have to like
predict what the enemy is going to
attack you with and then you need to
counter them
with uh like the with whatever yeah with
whatever counter so
i don't think it's terribly interesting
um
but yeah i don't know i guess it is the
most sort of like
beginner-friendly version of monster
hunter yeah it's it's a turn-based
turn-based rpg so it's not necessarily
like you're going out and hunting
monsters and
walloping them with big-ass hammers and
[ __ ] uh it's
it's uh because like i don't know
turn-based rpgs that's kind of my thing
uh but i don't know it's it's cool
maybe uh i don't know if i can put more
time into it though i think i don't
think that's the
i don't think that game is for me so uh
that and
one more thing i've been watching a
little uh korean drama called
vincenzo on netflix yo
what is that that's some [ __ ] that's
poppin it's about uh a korean dude who
grew up in
italy who got uh who got into the mafia
oh my god he's like
he's like an elite mafia member and then
he goes back to
he uh goes back to korea to like settle
something that
um that was like happening long ago
and it is so fun it's a dark comedy and
a like
and a very serious drama at the same
time it is so good
it is so good that sounds really i'm on
episode 15. oh my god there are so many
hot dudes in this yeah i just looked at
the
poster i don't know i don't know if
y'all are into like
k-pop stars but uh my boy tachyon from
2pm
oh my god he's a i swear he is the
finest dude i've ever seen in my life
and he's not the star but he's like a
very important character in it but oh my
god and the main dude oh my god he's
he's got oh my god everyone the guy on
the poster
who i assume is the main guy is yeah an
absolute 10 out of 10.
yeah but he's very disgusting
give him his roses you know what i'm
saying um
speaking of netflix because i didn't
know this was even happening so consider
this a psa
but the naked director season two has
just dropped and like the naked director
michael i think you and john luke would
actually love it if you haven't seen it
it's uh it's basically like you know
it's about yes
it's very very yakuza it's about the um
the guy from the 80s who wanted to make
oh
proper porn in japan
oh and then you made it but like
i don't know if i want to see kill you
[ __ ]
we all know he doesn't i think he's
it is amazing like it is so funny it is
a real
it's really wacky the naked director
naked
um but season two just dropped and it's
based on a real story as well which
makes it
even wilder so mexico was telling me
about it and he just
all he said to me was uh it's got big
yakuza zero energy and i said
yeah say less i'm in let's go
so i definitely i got this very yeah
it's very good you should
you should both definitely check out
hell yeah yeah say less
uh jake what you've been up to
uh i just finished psychonauts for the
first time since 2004.
or 2005. whenever it came out 2005. i
was a bit nervous about replaying it
uh which then i saw kurt's video which
was really good
uh and i was like okay i'm gonna replay
it and talking to him he was also
nervous about replaying it but
ended up enjoying it quite a bit uh but
man that game is so good the platforming
has not aged well but
the the settings the design the
characters the levels
the characters like the art direction is
timeless it's so good yeah
i am the milkman
is probably one of the most memorable
levels in a game for me but i was
surprised
every level in that game i remembered
surprisingly well
for only having played this game once in
2005 i was like yeah i remember
the bounce party that you go to yep i
remember the uh the
bull run that you do later on it's it's
so good if you haven't played it
highly recommend giving it a shot it's
on game pass uh
and you know the sequel is coming out
very soon and i'm just amazed that we're
even getting a sequel i think
uh yeah it got announced in 2016 and i
remember
this is the only thing i've ever backed
was psychonauts 2 sequel
and it was supposed to come out in like
2018. it still says that on the
fig page too that's it
but it you know if it's a good game
that's okay i'll wait as long as i need
to wait
i i'm shocked how much uh cause
like i i've been playing it for the
first time actually um i'm like part way
through it
i love it it's great but i like i
started paying more attention to
psychonauts 2 because i've
been playing the first one now and i'm
like oh yeah i won't play second house 2
now because this is dope
and i am shocked how much it just looks
exactly like psychonauts 1 but like
better like the gameplay and the like
characters i was like
oh this is just the same game but like
made in 2021
in like a good way like i was like oh
wow like it's not like they're trying to
like
it's not like a beyond good and evil 2
situation where it's like y'all wanted
psychonauts too well
here it is and it's like all this like
yeah it's like nope
it's just psychonauts 2. it's that same
game
but we made a sequel and i'm like hell
yeah yeah i'm very excited i'm amazed
because i think in curt's video he said
that by the end of the year it only sold
100 000 copies and it's just
to me it's amazing amazing that uh like
double fine survived that like how
how like that that's so i don't know
there's there must have been people who
are very much believed in
tim schafer and that team's visions in
order to
stick with them because well they had a
they had a deal for a little while with
was it thq where they had to make like
three games for them oh maybe that was
like stacking
costume quest oh yeah yeah yeah uh
trench that was it i think it was thq
but like that was
that was a big part of the the the uh
the double fine timeline that was like
uh
that was after brutal legend which also
i want to say
yeah i think brutal legend was a bit of
a flop as well
i love the religion it was a good game
this great game
but yeah but apart from that i've been
i've been playing dead by daylight
the first time i've played it uh it is
it i i
i love it and hate it at the same time
uh just because
coming into that game five years in
there is so much to learn
uh there's so many different killers
there's so many different survivors all
with different perks and abilities
but the core gameplay is like so
interesting and fun and every match
feels different
and different things can happen and it's
very exciting but like
man i get frustrated sometimes because i
found out last night that because i had
never played against michael myers
michael myers doesn't make
like normally when a killer is close you
can hear your heartbeat
but for some reason that doesn't happen
with michael myers so like three of us
are surrounding a generator fixing it
and all of a sudden he just comes
through and slashes and so
like what how are we supposed to know
and then we look it up and like oh okay
he can't
run but he no one knows when he's there
wow
okay that's kind of cool but yeah that
game's a lot but it's very good it once
again
saw it on game pass and matt padgett was
like i really want to play this and i
was like all right i'll give it a shot
is the resident evil crossover yet yeah
i think it
i mean technically it's done but i think
you can still get those characters and
the map is still there so i've just been
playing as
uh i've been swapping between jill and
leon
yeah there's silent hill in there as
well like
there's silent hill uh there's a silent
hill map too but
i it it does not fit the game at all
it's multi-story so you don't know if
someone's actually close to you if
they're just
on the floor above you uh it's way too
small it
like i i just leave whenever that map
comes up which
sucks because the matchmaking in that
game is really slow at least on xbox you
can wait up to 10 minutes to get into a
game
that sucks i need i want to try that
game i've heard so much about it
um you should play with us it's a good
time
all right cool i've been playing a lot
of valorent
that's pretty much the only thing i've
been playing lately
we played sea of thieves as well and
i've been like playing i'm working my
way from mass effect but the game that
i'm like
focused on is valerian right now just
trying to get good at it and uh
it's a it's a great game it's a good
time i'm doing you're also very good at
it you're dropping clips into
um like our chat and like discord that
we do
that clip you put up on twitter the
other day
there was like a full team wipe like
it's like four versus one
and like i i was just like i'm dead and
i was like
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna wait for
them to come to me a little like
patient strategy and that was my first
time playing yoru the character i was
i've never played that character before
um so i was like i don't know how
usually when i i usually main
jet who uh is is my girl
um hopelessly in love with jett um
she's amazing she's an airbender um but
like uh
someone beat me to selecting her
insta-locked and i was like i guess i'll
play euro
yoru is like a little anime boy um and
he's like able to
mess with like time not time like space
so basically he can like teleport and
he's got a flashbang and he can also
create like an apparition of himself
that he can send out and then
teleport positions with them which is
really cool but like so i was like i'll
try him out
um and i was just got really really like
lucky with like the fact that i needed a
flashbang
in that exact moment and i happened to
be the character that had the flashbang
if i was jet i would have had to like
there's so many things that fell into
place in that moment there was like
i took out two of them because they came
in in like um
towards me and then one of them was
hiding around the corner but the only
reason
i knew that they were there is because i
threw that flashbang
and they reacted by just firing so i saw
the bullets coming
so i was like if i was jet i wouldn't
have been able to do that
i would have like thrown my cloud burst
down which is another kind of like aoe
smoke effect but they wouldn't have
needed to fire so it was like perfect
moment a bunch of things
and also if you the wildest thing is if
you look i had six bullets
left in my magazine going up against two
enemies
like so i like had the perfect amount of
bullets
the last bullet that i hit the final
enemy ended
and um a reload animation started
and like i didn't immediately think to
switch to my knife so i let the reload
animation play out
which meant the bomb got one like got
closer to exploding
and then i immediately switched to my
knife and ran over so like i i think i
defused the bomb on the very last second
like the last
last second and i was like [ __ ] that was
wild
um but like i think that's going in like
you know the
the lad who does highlight reel um oh
yeah he hit me i was like can i can i
put that in there i was like yeah go for
it
hey yeah i was like i was watching i was
watching that clip and uh maybe you made
my butt clinch
so i've been playing like we played jake
and i played a bit as well like we
played
over there was it last weekend last
weekend yeah yeah
oh yeah i'm not very good at this and
then you were near the top of the
leaderboard every time
but that was playing on the us server so
i had mad lag as well
so like even better like it was me
jake uh matt was there as well and then
played with melissa who's a friend um
and tucker
who's in the us like friend and friends
that i met through like
andy cortez's streams and that kind of
stuff um
and yeah whenever i play with andy or
melissa or tucker or
or like maddox those group of people
it's i have to play an american service
and it's like it genuinely feels like
training in the hyperbaric time chamber
in dragon ball z
like where uh 10 ping 15 yeah
150 so it's like 157 so like everything
i have to do early
and nothing feels like it's hitting um
but i like play
with i play with andy soldier as well
it's the same thing um
and then i go back into my eu servers
and i feel like rock lee after he's
dropped his weights
and i'm just like running around just
head showing
everyone it's wild but yeah that game
isn't that game is so so satisfying
and um yeah they do they there's so many
smart things happening in their game
um like my favorite thing is like when
you get consecutive kills every time you
kill someone
it plays like a musical note and then if
you keep changing
together and like if you do like loads
of kills in a row it's just like
it's they make killing so satisfying in
that game and because it's like one
click as well
like if you're like good i've reached a
point where i'm so focused on just
trying to one tap everyone
this is so satisfying to like see an
enemy
just put your crosshair on them and
click once and they're gone
and like you're like this feels so good
and then you go back and then i like i
love
overwatch but like i go back to
overwatch and i'm like
just firing into shields for like 20
minutes at a time for an engagement and
it's just like
i miss just being like like just it all
being skill based
instead of like all these wacky like and
we have a friend who used to
who we play a bunch again we used to
play way more with called fa
and um he would describe overwatch's
mario party
first person shooter yeah and like now i
feel it now i get what he's talking
about because it's just
season it's silly season constantly like
especially after playing loads of like
um valerian and cs but yeah i'm trying
to get more people
to play with me because like um
especially in the uk side like no one in
the uk already plays it
that much i'm trying to get dave on it
um so i mostly just stream it and
and do like spike rush and and i just
got into ranked the other day and played
my first ranked match and lost because
my team was being
real weird about it um but like i'm
addicted to that now
it's all i'm playing damn that's what's
up that is what's up and you know what
else is up news we don't have a lot of
news except we have a lot of news
um but we're just gonna get through it
real quickly so you have a choice here
do you wanna hear about someone going to
jail or do you want to hear about
companies being brought up
for jail jail you want to he's getting
locked up yeah
he's getting locked up yeah he's getting
locked up smallville actor
alison mack has been sentenced to three
years
she blackmailed
coerced women into joining a sex cult
and she gets
three years so people who don't know
she was part of nexium uh the cult uh
that was kind of like headed up by keith
ranieri and was like
they recruited people as like sex slaves
for this
this to this dude who's an absolute top
10 [ __ ] herb
like how are you falling for this like i
looked at him and i was like they're
like and i watched the documentary on
hbo was it called again
oh yes um the vow the vow or something
like that so i i
like i listened to the podcast about it
read loads about and then hbo did the
documentary so that was my first time
actually seeing him
and the people in there like they're
like yeah he was very charismatic and he
was very like handsome and they cut to
and i'm like
this dude's a herb what are you talking
about like how much dance is this like
who's
like why are you why are you standing
this guy come on
that's like the the biggest proof that
like brainwashing is very very real
because if you can convince a bunch of
women to like do
insane [ __ ] for him it was a self-help
cult yeah meets multi-level marketing
scam
yeah with like a fraternity and a
sorority
within it yeah and they specifically
targeted
actors in vancouver and la who were like
once famous but were struggling so like
they got a bunch of people from
battlestar gold yeah grace park
tried to or was it part of it for a bit
yeah um
she tried also yeah cali from battlestar
was a big one
that she tried to get kristen crook who
played lana
lang in smallville and small yeah um i
was i was my massive crush
on her yes does it say i watched
smallville only because she was in it
um and and like yeah she she got a lot
of celebrities in there so
um she going to jail for three years
should be longer
um but yeah i don't know what's going on
with keith ranieri he should be like
in jail forever
damn see you later suckers next news
story
playstation buying everyone up they've
bought house mark
creators of a return oh you say
playstation's bought house
they bought three houses yeah they
bought fire emblem three houses
uh so yeah playstation has bought a
house mark
nothing more to that really um just a
great uh story for house mark really
they
they create a bunch of games and then
they were like nobody
buys all kind of games anymore so we're
going to make a new kind of game and
then it was
great and now sony were like we're going
to buy you
yay sony has also
today um on
yesterday by the time you listened to
this purchased nyx's software
um it was basically a
studio created out of former rise of the
tomb raider
developers i think it was um
or they they made the xbox 360 version
of rise of the tomb raider sorry
and they worked on marvel's avengers and
they make loads of pc
ports so um bloodborne pc port win
uh is what i'm saying uh and then
funcom has uh purchased a studio
called the outsiders which was uh
set up by david goldfarb formerly of uh
battlefield developer dice
and that is the news for this week
what we're gonna do now is move on to
jacob mccourt's episode 100 quiz
created by jacob macau wholesome jacob
awesome i'm very intrigued by this yes
is there a quiz about the podcast is it
a quiz about
it's a quiz about the podcast uh we have
a math
section and then we have a memory
section oh no
we'll start with the math section last
section for the 50th we did
jacob also yeah he hit me up and he said
uh do you want me to do a 101 like i did
with the 50 and i'm like absolutely
yes because that was a very good time so
all right why don't we just get this
started
uh first question this is the math
section
how many episodes are actually in the
feed hint
it's not oh well how many how many um
like
spoiler reviews spoiler reviews
i think a hundred and oh how are we
doing this are we
chiming in are we going around the room
we call around
around the room and i don't know the
answer either i haven't looked at any of
the answers all right
i'm going to say 109. i'm going to say
that i'll say 108.
oh uh i was going to say 108 but i'll
say 110.
dang i was gonna say one time i'm going
to say 106.
i'm going to say i guess i gotta go
111 uh all right
the answer is uh
109 technically oh
but technically 110 if you count this
episode
oh hey not in the feed yet though sorry
yeah all right uh
total hours podcasted oh my god
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get a calculator
up and say
uh what average two hours per yeah
it's like one two thirty 30 120.
[Music]
i'm gonna say i'll go on time i'm gonna
say 222
a lot of hours bro 175. i'm just going
to say 200.
i'm going to say 163 hours and 30
minutes
i'll say like you know the vibes 210
okay
all right and the answer is oh
a hundred and fifty eight and five only
14 hours
so is that michael i guess since i'm the
closest yeah
yeah i thought we did a bunch of three
hours or two and a half hour once we
just started we've
done a couple of those um we haven't
done that many i think we've only done
like two or three
that have gone that high um
what is the average length of the
podcast across
all episodes i'm going to say one hour
and 40 minutes
i was going to say one hour 15 minutes
i'm gonna say
uh how do i i in an hour
and an hour does somebody say hour 25
minutes
no no that's that's what i'm going with
i'm actually gonna say an hour and 23
minutes i changed my mind
i'm gonna say one hour and 27 minutes oh
i'm sticking with my one hour and 40.
all right 87
so that's that's an hour and
that's an hour 27.
this is right on it holy i swear
i did not look at this before i mean you
can't because it
jacob literally damn only so i don't
know how you would look at that
he could have dm lucy too oh [ __ ] he
didn't
have episodes gotten longer or shorter
since episode
50. i'm going to say shorter yeah
for sure yeah sure that we've made
concert efforts to make them shorter
yeah shorter i think so it's all right
because like when we used to do
do them in office it's like yo vibin you
know
yeah full point is coming out how many
seconds were wasted cracking four points
into the microphone
uh the answer is shorter by 12 minutes
wow hell yeah all right this is more
[ __ ] up you're doing math
have episode titles gotten longer or
shorter since episode 15.
well i have that one episode title
that's got the
maybe the record for longest uh i'm
gonna say longer probably
yeah longer i'm gonna say
sure yeah i'm gonna say shorter because
we used to like list
everything and yeah we've just sort of
gone for like jokes
i guess we had a period where we would
put people's names in them because we
had guests
and then we had not as much as yeah yeah
but like then we would list games
in and stuff we were talking about for a
period
all right let's see yeah probably
shorter than i'll just change my hands
yeah i'm changing the shorter too
oh my god all right i was gonna stick
with longer but the answer is shorter
by a little over one character oh
i love i love the very specificness of
the map down here this is amazing uh
how many different people have appeared
on the show
oh different people oh my god um
remember four five plus including yes
yeah
yeah i get them on a third time get them
here
i'm gonna say like 18. i'm gonna say 17.
i was gonna
say 30. yeah i'm gonna say like 22.
i'll just say 20. i had a you had like
oh yeah various folks from around our
office we've had guests
i was gonna say 27. i'm gonna say 21 21.
okay i'm gonna stick with mine um
i got 21 people to go whoa
66. what the [ __ ] wow do we even know
i guess if you count like is this
counting just games for after dark are
we counting like spoiler reviews because
then you add in like max and
yeah i guess if you're having spoiler
reviews if can't spoil it if it's in the
field
it's in the feed i can't even think of
66 people though i know
next episode you guys need to try to
name everyone who's been on the podcast
yeah oh man there's a bunch of folks
that we had like as guests like
mcfixer was on and simon cardy
greg shinobi yeah
yeah i guess we did have a lot of people
yeah yeah that's a good point damn
[Music]
all right 66.
all right okay no more people allowed on
who will be our 69th guest though no new
friends uh
i don't know phil spencer yeah phil
yeah what do you got phil smith
i'm i'm i'm good uh which people have
appeared
on the most shows so top five
top five people who appeared on the most
i'm gonna say definitely tam and
lucy
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't think i think jake
jake callie lucy
[Music]
yeah been there's have been lots of
people i didn't make
ben i don't well i
it i think it's me lucy tamore uh cali
and john nuke
yes me too yeah all right uh yes that is
correct
jake has been on 84
times lucy has been on 66 times
cali has been on 64 times
i've been on 52 times and timur has been
on
49 times let's go that's surprisingly i
figured uh
i'd be the lowest but you guys still got
some catching up to do yeah
before you reach the pod father yeah
uh ooh this might get all depressing
what percentage of the show has been
from home
oh no i think i know the exact number
for this
i think i'm pretty sure it's like
60 60 yeah 60. i'd say 66 percent
i'm going to go 69 let's go this is i
think 65 65 i think is it it's 65 or 66
i'm willing to bet
concluding this episode i'll say 64.
okay answer is 82
oh really i guess because we did more
more
there were more uh we did more spoilers
yeah
[Music]
but i think our last one in the office
was like 34 35
or something and i remember it was it
was peter brown's last episode
or it was peter brown's last day oh yeah
it was the last day in the office had
been canceled and we were talking about
e3 being canceled
there's a lot of things that make me
feel like depressed by the passage of
time lately
that isn't near the top now you're
welcome wait what what percentage
18 82 two percent of our buckets
two percent
[Applause]
that whole set is gone for reals yeah
yeah that can't be right rip
i mean the couch we stopped the couch i
don't think yeah we still have all the
the bits
but it's just not in that room we moved
the floors you know
we'll have to set up a new place all
right so moving on to the episode
memories section
uh on episode 52 of the show
callie and lucy both said that they
cackle uh that they cracked this
beverage
at the same time uh they went on to say
that if this
drink maker sponsored the show they
would change the name of the show
what drink was it white claw yeah it's
kind of
like it's faster was it white claw
i was i'd figured it'd be a four point
that's got to be
yeah what do we have to name the flavor
uh it'll be lime for lucy
okay so white claw lime uh white claw
raspberry for cali
i don't think we jacob probably doesn't
know the flavors
he does not know the flavor the answer
was indeed white claw and you guys said
you would rename the show
to the white claw cast that's pretty
good wow
[Laughter]
game spot after claw very good um
yeah and i stand by it white clothes are
expensive in the uk
so why call if you're listening hollow
white claw and cold fresh bombay mix hit
us up
i will take diet coke though uk diet
coke is so much better than american
dairy
yes
i don't like diet coke so i'd be willing
to i'd be willing to try it see if i
like it better
do that real coke bro uh oh no
next question does chris from dayton
ohio still listen to the show
no no he doesn't oh unless jacob is
included
and here's a special guest video it's
chris from daytona
he's going to appear in this in this
zoom call i pulled something like h3h37
oh no what a [ __ ]
what a nightmare
uh the answer no one knows
that's that's that's true too it's true
it's true i've tried
that's true yeah uh
uh what friend of the show got a feature
on episode
57 even though he was mostly just
screaming in the background
and i felt bad because people probably
clicked on it thinking greg miller would
be
all right
uh yes the answer was indeed greg miller
uh
which promotional boos got lucy james
and ryan peterson very drunk in the
middle of a tuesday afternoon
shoot shoots this is a game of thrones
was it game of thrones here yes it was
it was game of thrones game of thrones
wine
is that twice that you've done a
yesterday
with mike maherty yeah uh
yeah so if you send promotional wine
i will drink it we'll appear on our
planet
uh yeah the uh there was the assassin's
creed wine with mike and then
ryan and i drank the uh game of thrones
wine which was
very strong was it why or was it was it
oh was it
yeah it was like eight percent beer damn
yeah it was good the standard let's keep
going
i like a full point who won the great
console debate
in episode 67. oh
i know that answer i know i think it was
i think it was michael yeah i'm pretty
sure it was michael
speaking of embarrassing matt padgett
and jacob mccourt does a
uh trivia show and he had me and matt
paget on and matt patrick was beating me
the entire time and i beat him right at
the end if you want to see the ultimate
disrespect
shout out to jacob macor for doing that
and also it is it is embarrassing
matt didn't talk to me for like two
weeks after that oh my god
oh it is like he was beating me by a
huge lead the entire time
and then there was one question where he
gambled all those points and i gambled
almost oh
no last question one it was about advent
rising which for some reason i know
about that game because i played it and
he was like i've never heard of this
before
damn so shout out to jacob mccourt again
thank you uh was the 69th episode
60 minutes long
yes no i'm gonna say no no
that feels way too short no yeah it was
not it was not right
it was though uh how long did it take
the team to say
nice on the 69th episode
seven seconds well i'm gonna say you
gotta count 30 seconds for the intro
song to play and then uh
hey what's up focus uh introducing this
person
and then nice so i'm going to say like
40 seconds
i'm gonna say 10 seconds i said seven so
attack uh well because then if you're
counting the intro unless the intro was
something like welcome to a very nice
episode of games for after dark
well i think i said welcome to episode
69 and then everyone just said
nice yeah i think we all said nice as
our intro i said hello and welcome to
episode 69 of games for after dark nice
i think that's all it was yeah like it's
like i'll say
i'll say 17 seconds okay and you guys
aren't counting the
the intro oh i'm counting the intro i'm
counting the intro
the interest i've gotten the music
interesting 30 seconds the music
controls 30 seconds i'm counting down
okay really six
42 seconds i was gonna say 45.
okay i guess he didn't count the intro
then because nine seconds so
but but if we'll we'll we'll
retractively off 30 off
so okay close so i said basically 12.
uh which game won the
uh best game cali's dad played in the
2020 after dark awards
it's definitely like a call of duty
yeah dude
metro doom 2016. i'm going to say it's
metro respect stops the line
i think it's metro it might have been oh
spec ops
2020 2020 i think it was metro yeah
okay because he started reading the
novels after that yeah
yeah i miss hearing about kelly's dad
yeah what's he up to what game is he
playing i'm just getting quickly text
and i go yo how's your dad
get him on not a weird way you should
play valerian with callie's dad that's
because
yeah damn let's go uh the answer was
metro
last light nice
when did the theme for game spot after
dark change
oh everybody so 70 something there was
no rhyme or reason i remember one day
jake was just like i'm changing the
theme
no it was because we changed the logo oh
it wasn't because we changed the logo
oh okay i figured we needed a song
refreshing and like three people were
like
the intro you have sounds like softcore
porn music and i was like
i mean i'm okay with those vibes but we
should probably change them
i never thought of that it's called off
the dock for a reason yeah uh
it's episode 70. episode 69
episode 75. i'll get one of these i'm
gonna say 77
no i'm gonna say 72 71
i'll say 69 yes go sean luke
uh 75. okay
how many games got spoiler casts what do
you think
well yakuza personal persona
final fantasy vii control
personas last of us yeah
so i'm going to say medium medium medium
yeah i'm going to say eight well if
there's 109 episodes
strikers one episode would be striker
yeah jake was on strikers right trayla
yep so eight so yeah eight
nine the answer is eight misspoke
band we already named all the games yes
it was control final fantasy last of us
cyberpunk the medium yakuza persona 5
and personified strikers
thanks hey uh i don't even remember you
saying this
uh john we talked about the podcast
rules on episode 88 what's the first
rule of podcasting according to him uh
don't don't talk in podcast have a good
microphone
i remember this moment but i don't
remember what you said i don't remember
this at all everyone should have the
same microphone um
i think it's like i think it was oh no
it was don't don't eat on
mike or something like that yeah
no i mean that is a good rule i but i
think it was a joke i think it was like
you should eat on mike or something
okay uh no slurping or slurping
the answer is uh don't speak until
you're introduced
that's right oh yeah okay i remember
that
okay that [ __ ]
okay this is a one for not michael to
answer it says what is michael's typical
greeting when introduced on the show
uh i know what it is
you're
[Music]
yeah see all i remember what i remember
is at the end you always say follow me
on twitter for all my
goals
and uh what did you do what was the
other one what to do what to do
yeah i would say what to do it's
probably
what it do baby yeah that's exactly what
it is
baby shout out to kawhi leonard yeah
a few episodes ago lucy spoke about
tam's superpower
what is it
oh i know what it is yeah i know what it
is
it was it was with regards to death loop
the death block preview if i remember
correctly
oh like say what you were talking about
like tam's like amazing ability to just
like
just write the most amazing like pros
possible even though like according to
tam he was literally just rolled out of
bed and just
yeah two hours late he had two hours
sleep and he was under a really tight
deadline and he
wrote something incredible is that my
superpower
whatever yeah i think that was it i'll
take it it was like he could
pull great sayings expressions and jokes
out of his ass at a moment's notice
oh that's gross why would you do that
something's got to go in those booties
okay
in episode 96 michael fantasy booked
episode 100 with four people
not from gamespot who did he put on the
show wow
uh i don't even remember that i don't
even remember probably i'm gonna see
myself
maybe i think i guess that would i would
love that yeah um
damn i don't even remember saying that
phil spencer
who was the other one jan jan yeah
or jan would be producing it yeah
all stars baby okay we are completely
wrong we didn't get any of that right
okay oh sweet it was now i want that
podcast
it was uh jake callie peter and danny
o'dwyer
oh i said that this sounds weird i would
what the [ __ ] shout out to michael for
creating the white podcaster
i'm just gonna say like why would i cast
a fully white podcast i would never do
that
i think it was probably sad that we
weren't there anymore i think that's a
good crew though like i would i would
listen
to that i think it was like uh something
i was like
i don't know off the top of the brain
when yeah
i would never do that i'll just be
daniel dwyer that's fine yeah
all right uh final question have there
been
more shows with the new logo or the old
logo
old one right yeah because you said you
switched around 60 or seven oh you know
what yeah probably old one then
yeah no i think i think itunes also
has an updated like if you scroll back
far enough it still has the old
it does it does which is actually kind
of cool um i'm gonna still say new i'm
gonna i'm gonna guess now
more with the new one more i'm gonna say
more or with the old
uh the answer is new logo uh oh
29 with the old logo and 71 percent with
the new
logo okay maybe i didn't change the song
with the logo yeah
i am shout out to shout out to miranda
for instigating that
yeah that's it that's great uh and that
is the end of the jacob mccourt 100
episode quiz thank you jacob
appreciate it and with that
let's move on to listener questions uh
if you would like to email this
very podcast you can hit us up at
afterdark podcast at
gamespot.com or you can join our discord
server if you want entry into discord
server you can dm either me
or lucy and we will run a background
check
we'll check your uh your kind of credit
levels
credit rating and then we'll decide
whether you're allowed in or not
um first question comes from maria or
aka serious business in the discord uh
jake can you read that please because we
know you love to read out loud
it's too long someone else read it
michael i am read that
ah [ __ ] okay uh when you reach the age
of 100 in the uk you qualify for a
birthday message from the queen
is that true you do you get a telegram
from the queen uh
if all liz was uh to send a game invite
to gsad
uh for its 100th episode what game do
you think she'd want to play with you ps
congrats on reaching 100 episodes this
podcast and uh the batch of good eggs on
the g
sad discord make for one of the best
communities in video games
and thanks for being such a positive
force and keeping all the wrongins and
bad vibes at bay
yeah shout out to maria uh
she'd want to play wii sports golf with
that golden nintendo
oh with the golden wings undertale
reigns genocide run the pope's got
undertale i can play undertale with the
queen too mount your friends
her husband's kicked it so she wants to
see some swinging wangs now
uh i'm gonna say
[Music]
crusader kings three
yeah i think i think she's got some good
tactics she could uh help me out with
oh my god i mean the royal the royal
family is the very definition of failing
upwards so i doubt they'd be very useful
in any sort of actual strategy
i would i would i would just for the
record i would i would like to
decline the invites i'd be like i ain't
playing [ __ ] with you
guys i just feel like she wouldn't
understand how to use party chat
properly she wouldn't
have to call him
[Music]
the mic would be too close to her face
and it would be
real weird oh there's an enemy behind
you
why does she sound like yoda
jean-luc can you read the next question
please this is from
jeremy it says in honor of the 100th
episode what's everyone's
favorite games that they've put 100 plus
hours into
oh uh i feel like this is cheating
because you're obligated to put at least
100 hours into it which is a persona 4
golden
yeah not true not true i finally beat
persona 4 gold and took me like 45 hours
oh yeah [ __ ] though you skipped like
that's true
i cranked i made it as easy as possible
because i played through the first half
of that game twice and i was like i'm
just gonna get through this quick
just yeah damn okay all right congrats i
respect it so
technically i've probably played that
game over 100 hours oh yeah
yeah uh for me it's the same with
jean-luc like persona 5 royal but also
final fantasy 14. mm-hmm
damn i'm saying you have to put 100
hours of them [ __ ] yeah
probably overwatch maybe yeah i was
gonna say like mass effect
yeah mass effect mine's bloodborne easy
mine's probably overwatch actually at
this point yeah
but one's mine jake what was yours
probably the witcher 3 but i've also
played 100 hours of siege more than 100
hours of siege
uh and that's the game that i still come
back to regularly or uh
pub g is is one that i've been thinking
about replaying lately and i put like
450 hours in that game
jonathan i remember those days kind of
what
is that what the tease was full they
have jonathan franks reading like
lore entries or something he's like he's
like sitting at a desk and he's doing
like
lore stuff for the pub g universe uh
he's um from star trek he's uh oh okay
what's his name uh uh number one riker
yeah he's uh unfortunately uh
get him on that he's also the guy who
does uh that meme
well what was that no it's a lie i don't
think so
yeah that's unsolved it's not true is it
on the inside
yeah he also directed the thunderbirds
movie yeah
great good job to him prolific prolific
it would seem keep him busy
uh lucy can you read this question from
jacob mccourt please
yes jacob of course says have you all
done or heard of the centurion
in the centurion you do a hundred shots
of beer or mixed drinks in a hundred
minutes
i do not condone heavy drinking but if
you were to do this in honor of 100
episodes
what alcohol would you choose and what
songs would be on your centurion
playlist
thank you and congrats on 100 episodes i
have not personally tried it
but i have been there when people have
and it
is messy yeah beer sounds easy but it's
not don't choose beer because that
should catch mostly
well you're mostly just drinking like
foam at that point because you're just
pouring more and more and more
and you will throw up yes
i was like i think it was like hour a
half hour of power or some [ __ ] and
yeah did you do like 30 shots of beer in
30 minutes
and we're like hell yeah i could i can't
see shotgun how many yeah sounds easy
until i get it it's not um but i'd be
down to try it
uh i'm gonna yak so you gotta cover me
there um but
wha wha wha what's what was the other
part what songs would you do what songs
be on your playlist
no hands from um from um
brick squad waka flocka and roscoe dash
no hands that's that's a great song to
drink too
oh maria asks as a as a follow-up to
that is
um if you don't want to drink and for
tam uh sub in a food of some sort like
hot wings
chicken nuggets sour sweets etcetera i
think i could go through 100
hot wings pretty easily
if there's no time limit no there is
you have to have one a minute no one
minute 100
no yeah i cannot do that one piece of
bombay mix
one piece of bombay mix for me you
couldn't even eat the
top wings or chicken nuggets that fast
like i think skittles i could probably
do sour skittles
because you don't even have to chew
those you just have to swallow them
and they smell like pills yeah just take
them like pills okay
you know what i would do those um sour
patch kids watermelons
oh yeah they are my favorite that's got
a hundred
and 100 minutes though it's supposed to
be kind of rough though you're not just
supposed to pick something you really
like in it yeah but no but it's a sour
candy and so like even if i've had a
handful of it it's still yeah
it starts to tear up your mouth yeah i
can't imagine what your stomach's gonna
feel like after that [ __ ] broke
exactly that would be awful all right
final question
comes from kevin jake can you read that
it's literally two lines man
hey after darkers congrats on episode
100
if you could send your episode oneself a
message about podcasting
what would it be i accidentally already
answered this
i'm pretty well done in the discord i
said that uh
i would get ready for work from home or
podcast from home
because that's gonna be most the show
yeah i would say to my episode oneself
uh you good dog
that's it just keep doing your thing man
ain't nothing ain't nothing just have a
fun time with you yeah
have a good time i think that would be
the message yeah make sure you're having
a good time
yeah yeah oh i think i know what i'd say
i think i would have told myself
to have more variety on the show like
more people from the office and stuff
like that
because that was we had like i don't
talk about too much we had kind of like
weird messaging where it was like try to
stick with the core cast
but like no one really said anything if
we deviated from that
so i wish i had like just had more of a
mix on
uh especially those earlier episodes
yeah those are not those earlier
episodes
but those like middle episodes when it
was just like the same four people
yeah there's there was a period where we
were being told how
growth can happen and it led to some
things that were
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
like it meant that we focused in
on a way that a format that was like
perhaps not the best
i would i mean like yeah i think it was
good like i think there were some good
aspects of it like
i think we definitely found the footing
in that show because of that
but like there were a lot of people that
i really wanted to get on that
it was just there were forces against
that and i was like all right no
yeah yeah i would i would go back and
say the same thing as well like try and
mix it up more
um and i mean that's that's something
that we'll probably
start we're doing a lot of now but i
think we'll probably start figuring out
um i think we'll do a do a a kind of
like
audit of the podcast anyway so we can
figure out what kind of
fun stuff that we can add to it if if
there was one
like one thing i would say i would
actually say to myself is that you don't
have to
say everything in one episode
yeah and i think that like when whenever
i got on i was like oh this is an
opportunity so i have to say everything
that i
want to say uh and it would take eat up
too much times like no we'll have
an opportunity to do this again sometime
before it's it's not
like a video where you have to get it
all out in this one video it's like
it's a series you're gonna have 100
episodes so you'll have an opportunity
to
get that thought out later down the line
if it doesn't need to be in this episode
so
i think that that's good advice yeah and
with that
comes to a close the hundredth episode
of gamespot after dark and lucy james's
1000th
video congratulations lucy and
congratulations to everyone who is
on this podcast and congratulations to
you jake
you made something that lasted a hundred
podcasts it's pretty impressive
i'm honest i'm surprised yeah i mean
obviously
given how podcasts like game spot have
gone in the past i was like yeah you
know maybe we'll get through 30 episodes
and then they'll be like
like people just get busy and things
but we stuck with it i mean you did big
there will be blood energy
i've abandoned my boy i've abandoned my
child
there's an ocean of podcasts on our feet
if i have a podcast and you have a
podcast
um but thank you for joining us jake
where can people find you
and what you up to these days uh you can
find me on twitter at jacob deck
if for some reason you listen to game
stuff shark and you're like man i just
need to hear more
jake decker uh i do a podcast with that
paget and one of my friends
stuart called uh the nuclear fridge and
this week's episode is just an hour
about splinter cell so if that sounds
like your kind of thing you should give
it a listen
uh do you guys make a version where it's
only your audio but you like cut out
like
matt like i would just i'll get on that
yeah i'll get all
right cool yeah like a special subscribe
patreon yeah patreon
yeah i love that it's a great podcast i
listen to it every week i'm a few
episodes behind because of
e3 but like it's a good fun time yeah um
thank you i highly recommend it
um michael what are you up to you find
me in all my [ __ ] at michaelpieheim
on twitter.com
and uh yeah uh gamespot.com as well
i don't know your boy's been going
through it so uh i don't know i got a
lot of [ __ ] to figure out my life
uh you can find you can keep up with it
probably on twitter
so uh i don't know him the peacetime
subpoena
jean-luc yeah you've been up to
me at john linksype um i've just been
doing a lot of behind the scenes stuff
i've been taking a break after after e3
and play for all
um but i'm gonna be doing some some cool
stuff you might see me in the
behind the scenes on a couple of cool
things you might not expect i'm kind of
excited about uh
so yeah should be fun fun fun changing
pace for uh
next week or two i have no idea what
you're talking about so i'm excited by
this oh man
lucy where are you where are you and
what are you up to
uh hopefully taking some time off yeah
i'm out next i'm out next week i'm out
next week
yeah um but i have been in the uk for
two months and i haven't managed to go
see my mum yet
and hell has no fury like a northern
woman scorned
so i will be going up to newcastle for a
little break which will be very nice and
i'll get to see my nieces
i'm on twitter at lucy james games um
only thing i've been up to really this
week
like decompressing from e3 and playful
uh is we
did a video time and i and chris morris
from the uk with the uh
devs behind mass effect uh some mac
walters brandon homes and melanie
faulkner
and they talked about sort of their
favorite moments from across the trilogy
and they sort of just break down like
what it was like
at the time working at bioware on those
scenes
um some cool stories specifically about
the creation of biotic charge which is
one of my favorite
abilities in the game um so that's up
now if you want to check that out sweet
and i'm on twitter at tomorrow h um
i'm also going to be taking next week
off but i'm going to i might pop in to
do the podcast if john luke will allow
it
um no no damn i hate to see it
i'm supposed to be the host as well i
can't see it
um but otherwise yeah you can find me on
twitter tomorrow h i'm also streaming
uh valorem now and then um on twitch
at tomorrow h there as well and that's
pretty much it we'll see you again next
week
uh in the meantime be cool look after
each other drink lots of water and get
loads of sleep
bye everyone thank you thanks for
watching
100 episodes to another hundred